NUMBERS.
SO THE U.S. GOVERNMENT HAS
DEFUNDED HORRIBLE IT'S LIKE
TORTURING KILLED DOGS FOR NO
GOOD REASON.
NOTHING USEFUL IN SCIENCE FROM
THE TORTURE AND YET DR. FAUCI
SPENT $400,000 THE TROPICALS AND
MESH CAGES WERE THE BEEN THE
DEATH.
SO THIS IS HORRIFYING IT SHOULD
NEVER HAPPEN HOW DO WE PREVENT
DOGS FOR ME MURDERED JUST SO
TONY FAUCI CAN SPREAD MORE MONEY
AROUND.
THE MORGAN ON THIS FOR A LONG
TIME TO SING THAT LAWMAKERS AND
THAT THEY'RE MAKING.
WERE GRATEFUL FOR HER EFFORTS
AND HAPPY TO WELCOME HER TONIGHT
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
TELL US HOW YOU CAN STOP THIS
OUR BILL IS ACTUALLY DIRECTED
PEOPLE WHO ADOPT AT SHELTERS.
>> IT'S WHAT DOGS AND CATS
SHOULD HAVE WHICH ARE POSTED AT
SHELTERS, HUMANE SOCIETIES, OR
SUCROSE SO THAT PEOPLE WHO ARE
ADOPTING UNDERSTAND WHAT EXACTLY
THE EXPECTATIONS ARE AND HAVING
AN ANIMAL.
>> Tucker: WITH THAT PREVENT,
DO YOU THINK THE TIDE OF CRUELTY
THAT YOU'RE SEEING IN THESE
POINTLESS EXPERIMENTS ON
ANIMALS.
PEOPLE ARE BEING PAID TO TORTURE
ANIMALS TO DEATH AND THERE'S NO
EVIDENCE THAT HUMAN LIVES ARE
SAVED BECAUSE OF IT.
>> THAT WOULD BE A COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT BILL AND WE DID WORK
ON A BILL THAT HAD TO DO WITH
COSMETICS AND PERSONAL HYGIENE
PRODUCTS SOLD IN CALIFORNIA THAT
SHALL NOT BE TESTED ON ANIMALS
SO THAT IS SOMETHING THAT
CALIFORNIA DID DO WE GOT SIGNED
INTO LAW, BUT THE CONVERSATION
THAT YOU'RE HAVING ABOUT ANIMALS
AND TESTING IT'S A WHOLE OTHER
ONE THAT WE WOULD LOVE TO
ADDRESS BECAUSE IT IS OUR
TAXPAYER DOLLARS THAT GO TO
ANIMAL EXPERIMENTS AND
UNIVERSITY ACROSS UNITED STATES.
SO NOT ONLY IS IT UNIVERSITIES
WITH OUR TAXPAYER DOLLARS IT IS
PUBLIC AND PRIVATELY FUNDED AND
A LOT OF THESE EXPERIMENTS HAVE
BEEN DONE BEFORE AND THEY DON'T
NEED TO CONTINUE AND THEY ARE
NOT ANIMAL TESTS THAT HAVE
HIGHER EFFICACY RATES THAT
SHOULD BE USED.
>> Tucker: I HOPE THIS IS A
GOOD STEP FOR DOING THAT COULD
COME OUT OF CALIFORNIA BECAUSE
MR. DOGS PEOPLE I KNOW MUCH
ABOUT IT.
>> THERE IS A DIRECT CORRELATION
THAT IS WELL DOCUMENTED IS THAT
YES